how many people worldwide will die from
coronavirus estimates range into the
millions but New York University law
professor Richard Epstein says such
guesses fail to take into account all
the actions that are already taking
place to contain and suppress the
pandemic in an interview conducted via
Skype Epstein who is also a fellow at
the University of Chicago's center for
clinical medical ethics explains his
math which draws on his work dealing
with the AIDS epidemic in the late 1980s
and 90s he also discusses why the
stimulus plans being flouted are
unlikely to help the economy in the
short run but will cause major problems
in the long run why he thinks local and
state governments are overreacting by
shutting down businesses and schools and
why he expects the crisis to ease up in
a few months as it already has in the
Asian countries at first
Richard I want to thank you for coming
to us via Skype
well it's something we could do online
without having to go outside some wall
for it okay yeah and that's even before
the corona virus hit right you know why
go outside
there's nothing one of the high-risk
types right it's something so can I ask
you do you worry about that at all I
mean this is a moment of mortality then
right much less than I should I suppose
but the reason I tend to worry about it
is not because I think that the odds are
very high since health fairies amongst
people who were 70 years old but you
have family and friends and institutions
and everybody else and even if you're
comfortable was going out and around
they're not comfortable with you going
out and around and so what happens is
the constant social pressures to take
maximum precautions tends to drive the
whole system downward and it's
reinforced by really powerful doomsday
scenarios which essentially say with
respect to the bad news we've only just
begun this is the tip of the iceberg
it's gonna last until August it's gonna
claim a million or a half a million
lives I think all of these forecasts are
technically wrong okay what they
influence behavior yeah let's talk about
that you add a piece that's up at
ricochet where you also do a bunch of
podcast ricochet the gray kind of
conservative or conservatory in'
podcasting and social media community
you you are you have a piece up there
where you're very skeptical of the idea
and we're seeing it more and more that
you know a million Americans 1.7 million
Americans according to the CDC's worst
case scenario might die from kovat 19 or
other kind of excrescences of the corona
virus why are they wrong about that well
I mean it's a question of how it is that
you sought to model these things from
initial data and usually when you start
dealing with very serious kinds of
attacks of which the Spanish flu in 1918
is perhaps the most important but there
were also AIDS attacks and for example
1981 and 82 what usually happens is
these diseases come on the on the scene
with a bang they're unexpected there's a
latent period people are very close
together there's usually a lot of
churning that starts to take place some
they're old people and so what happens
is this virus will start to spread
immediately very very fat so if you look
at the two hot spots that one can refer
to one of them is the cruise ship cruise
ships have all the people on them cruise
ships are very densely packed cruise
ships have common eating facilities
cruise ships have a single ventilation
system it's gonna be very likely that if
one person gets this virus it's going to
spread very rapidly to everybody else
and the same thing is true with the
old-age facility that is in Kirkland
Washington you have a group of people
who are in a nursing facility 80 years
or over and this virus starts to hit and
there's a latent period it will spread
very rapidly and to this day at least
25% of the deaths in the United States
have occurred in that one facility
average age of the people who died is
suddenly around 80 or 81 it's quite
clear that if you're a family member who
visits somebody there and you give hugs
and kisses and so forth you may have a
sufficiently large exposure that
notwithstanding your comparative youth
you too may suffer from that disease but
these conditions are really right then
what happens is how much do you
extrapolate from this and if you look at
the standard models there was a piece
which I thought frightening ly
inaccurate my Nick Kristof and a man
named Thompson in the New York Times on
Saturday and I had this huge speaking
curve peaking in July indicating nothing
much is going on then now but by then
we'd have 10 million cases and maybe a
10 percent conversion rate if we're
really good about it we make make it a 5
percent conversion rate so they're
estimating between 500,000 and a million
people dead and there's some people have
taken it even further I've heard numbers
up to 1.7 million and someone well you
start looking at the real numbers on the
ground
um the 25 people in the Kirkland
facility who were killed constitute
about 1/4 of the dead people in the
United States if you start looking at
the number of new cases and track them
fairly accurately they start to increase
but they don't show any kind of a
geometric improvement right now the
latest estimate is that were up to about
900 or a thousand cases per day which is
much lower than it was with respect to
the flu epidemic that we had this past
year people start to refer to the
Italians that
situation which is a bit more rapid but
Italy for some reason seem to have
terrible health even before this because
there were more deaths in a smaller
country from flu in Italy than there
were in the United States by about a 50%
margin so you're gonna see it one place
you'll see it and the other then of
course there's China and you know people
have been very upset about China but the
total number of deaths there is about
3,500 give or take and there are a large
number of cases that are unresolved but
certainly if you just simply look at the
resolved cases they're probably a ratio
it's under 5% of the people who got the
disease were killed the usual rule in
these things is that if a disease starts
to go on for a long time and doesn't
kill you it's probably going to be
relatively modest so the percentage of
death conversions you'll see in the
residual population is probably smaller
best guess is that the situation in
China will end up with about 5,000
people dead maybe even less than that
you try to take that over to America and
you now assume that all the surprises
out you're gonna start to see major
signs of adoptions now what are these
going to be well they're many of them
and they take place on different
timeframes but the first is these target
populations that are highly vulnerable
are going to be much more sealed off
than they've been before and that the
general population is by and large not
going to get this either very severely
or in very large quantities if you look
for example at the Korean situation they
had about 83 people dead but only two of
them were 50 years or younger and none
of them were under 30 and so you know
this immediately starts to say wait that
one's gone it's course as has the
Chinese one so what yeah you also see
something similar happening in Singapore
now South Korea and Singapore Taiwan
also gets high marks for testing early
and rapidly and ubiquitously as much as
possible but they interestingly South
Korea and Taiwan did not you know
contrary to China and actually the way
Italy has responded to not go into mass
quarantines and lock downs as quickly
they seem to focus the energy on actual
populations that were at risk or had
actually been shown to be infected
is that a better
way to deal with this kind of stuff I
certainly think so because if you start
looking at these ratios even in the
United States um the only people who
seem to be dying of this on high-risk
populations very high at 80 and over
high at 70 and over even at the highest
level is about 8% but one has to
remember these numbers are very gross so
if you're 80 years old and in a nursing
home and have other conditions like
diabetes and renal difficulties and so
forth you're really at risk for this
stuff but if you're 80 years old and you
can still play three sets of tennis
you probably biologically like somebody
who's 55 and so as you get older the
basic rule is that the variants and
fitness amongst all individuals starts
to increase so it's harder and harder
about older populations to make
generalizations that's why the cruise
ships and the nursing facilities are so
powerful because those are relatively
homogeneous population so let me ask you
something a little bit off I you know I
I both find your you know the way you're
talking about this both you know kind of
plausible highly plausible and also very
encouraging I feel the same way about it
and you know I'm glad to hear you kind
of spell out the logic of this why do
you think people are so invested in
immediately going to the worst-case
scenario and we've seen this on certain
precincts of the right but also at the
left and certainly throughout the media
this is people want yeah I don't want to
say that they want to see two million
people dead but they are talking as if
it is a fait accompli I think this has
to do with the same issue in connection
with global warming
I mean I'm generally pretty deep skeptic
about the fact that the world is going
to come to the end if you start looking
at all the short-term indicators none of
them indicate stuff but the alarmist
literature on this stuff is simply
enormous and the immediate data is not
Kerry is not respected well the same
thing seems to be happening here
everybody starts to think about where
space hypothesis and then you figure out
how it is you model them and so when the
New York Times presented its model with
this sharp peak and the sharp decline
you try to figure out what are the
assumptions behind it and essentially
what they did is they had themselves a
geometric progression with an expansion
ratio of two point
three people getting it for every one
person who has it
there's no time interval that's
specified in this and there's no sense
that as you go through iteration after
iteration that there's going to be some
kind of adaptive responses at all sorts
of levels which will change the numbers
so if you just do this it's an exercise
in geometry in mathematics it's not an
exercise in epidemiology let me give you
a comparison when the AIDS thing came
out in the 1980s I was at the time and
still am a fellow at the center for
clinical medical ethics at the
University of Chicago and I was working
on that and you know I started to
understand the way the patterns worked
and wives was rapid and then decline and
I got an email from a very distinguished
statistics attestation named Bill
Kruskal long deceased but an important
man and he wrote me the following email
I couldn't have an email but whatever
right he said hey he said you know I've
done the calculations on this and
humanity will be all extinguishes the
year 2006
so I said bill what are your assumptions
well he had a geometric progression he
assumed that every person would affect
so many people that the interval between
the next generation would take place and
this starts relatively slowly and by the
time to get the 2005 you've got 1
billion people dead in 2006 you got 2
billion people dead so I wrote him back
I said you're doing math you're not
doing epidemiology so let me give you
the following simple observation which
applies to AIDS but not of course to the
COBIT virus so if you're a monogamous
couple you're not gonna get this stuff
unless you get a butt fan tradition
which you don't test for and as the
behaviors start to become more fatal
people will start to go away from them
so bathhouses will close down and even
if they don't close down people aren't
gonna go to them so you have to do is
for each iteration you have to assume
two things one is going to be a longer
period between the spread from one
person to another and two you have to
assume that they're gonna be fewer
people who get it on the opposite and so
those two effects essentially are gonna
compound with each period now the third
feature which I developed then is
another story is that as you lengthen
the period between the first and the
second person there's going to be an
evolution in the virus so that it will
become more attend
so here's the story well I was gave this
thing to an interviewee from I think it
was either Time and Newsweek magazine
and they called me back the next day I
said professor I've seen you have to be
a doctor or an epidemiologist aren't you
I said no I'm just a plain old law
professor well I can't use your stuff if
it's even if it's true because you don't
have the right expertise so they called
me three times I kept on Italian I'm
just a law professor has a very deep
interest in evolutionary theory and
sociobiology and I've studied it in
quite detail for 20 years unrelated and
related to my legal work so when they
published the story they put me out as a
biologist or a doctor any honey couldn't
couldn't bear to stand it the other way
well what happens is let's just get the
simple point down as you wait between
people there are two effects that you're
gonna have to worry about when I talked
about on the paper the other not and the
first is the long do you go between
context which is gonna happen because of
all the adaptations we have the people
with severe conditions are gonna die off
before they spread it and if it's gonna
spread it's gonna be spread by people
whose virus is less potent which allows
them to live long so this means that not
only do you have the two factors that I
was talking about before long the gaps
and lower contact rates but you'll also
get yourself a weaker virus in the early
periods it may not be the very strongest
effect but you're talking about
iterations and cycles which may take
place every day or two or three and
suppose you assume a three-day cycle on
this thing and you've got 90 days you've
got 30 iterations you're gonna see an
attenuation of the virus
second thing is these things tend to
mutate very rapidly now what does that
mean well when you have a mutation you
can go one or two ways if it's gonna
make this stuff more severe it's not
gonna pass because people are gonna be
cautious if you make it less severe it's
gonna enter into the mix so if you take
all these effects into account the
prediction is that you should see an
attenuated virus and if you look at the
stuff that has taken place for example
in China and one um this thing was very
active until early February and then all
of a sudden with all these factors
working the things started to decline so
whereas the front story page story in
the newspaper was a hundred and fifty
people dead in Italy
most important story was that the death
rate in China was at that point 12 and
the new infection rate was 14 so this
means that within 2 months after the
beginning this thing is over and they're
projecting in the United States a peak
which is going to take place four months
later that is in July and then they have
it declining but there's nothing in
their function which explains why it
defines declines at all I mean the
original assumptions is just an
exploding machine so once you figure out
what the the decline is you have to
build that back into the model for the
earlier period this is very bad design
we've done by professional
epidemiologists that leaves me very very
nervous because they really don't
understand the economic incentive
structures that a positive virus is just
as it applies to human beings
so let's talk a little bit about some of
the adaptive measures that are taken in
order to kind of dispel a virus or a
pandemic you know an infectious disease
when it happens how do you feel about
things like closing schools or closing
bars or closing you know gyms where it's
unlikely that the people who are most at
risk for dying from this are going to be
congregating and in two ways I mean I
guess I would like to hear you judge the
response that has been put forth by city
city state and federal governments about
stopping certain types of activities is
that effective and then secondly from a
legal point of view what are what goes
into the you know the kind of
calculation of is this a is this a legal
idea or is this a good idea based on
limited government principles okay now
let's just do this last thing first and
then take the first thing what happens
is there's always been a long tradition
of limited police power and the big
exception to the limited police power
rule has always been the rules dealing
with this Mayu a major catastrophe and
so you could go back to the 1820s you
could go back to Roman times and the
moment you get floods the moment you get
earthquakes the moment you get invasions
essentially the rules of private
property are suspended and the courts
have basically decided in all of these
cases to stay out of this game so in one
very instructive opinion the Selective
Service cases
in the middle of World War one the judge
who decided on this was Mao on Pitney
he's one of the greatest unknown
justices of the Supreme Court and a very
consistent and rigorous classical
liberal and so when it came to the
question about whether or not the United
States could draft everybody in the
militias and put them into the Army he
just said we deferred to the political
branches of government we have
absolutely nothing to do about this
stuff
we're not war makers of war find it so
that's your libertarian judge you could
imagine how everybody else feels and
through all the Second World War when we
had the destruction of facilities in the
Far East as the Japanese advanced and so
forth the Caltex case all of these cases
would decide in favor of the government
so wait I'm sorry could you what was the
Caltech case it's a case in which United
States decides to blow up a private
facility to keep it out of the hands of
the Japanese okay I think they want to
claim it's a take the answer is yeah
well we did take it and we didn't take
it the Japanese would have taken it and
if the Japanese taken that they would
have put it into war again this is a
Caltech building in California no this
is in no this is a field assembly in the
line of the Japanese okay yeah it's the
necessity is only that we have had
situations with you tried to commandeer
an American facility during wartime at
home the steel seizure cases are the
chief one of that and there there's a
lot more resistance to doing it and
there's also much more willingness to
say hey you can buy your way to jet
planes you don't have to confiscate the
Lockheed faculty to do although and then
there's obviously and we're getting a
bit of feel but there's the Korematsu
decision as well which is scandal yes
that's absolutely one of the darkest
moments in a you could use fate
necessity in Korematsu the incarceration
took place in May of 42 and it was clear
by that time a Norwegian that it was
over there was the Battle of the Coral
Sea and shortly thereafter there was
Midway there was no need to do anything
whatsoever of that sort and Hoover said
and he was the hero on this I got all
the people I wanted on December 8th I
don't need this and who was responsible
for it you remember who the Attorney
General of the state of California it
was a man
who went on to head the Supreme Court
Earl Warren and you get a gold and he
was you know I I don't want it stars in
any context of yeah I am and then he was
so popular he became governor on both
the Democratic and Republican Party
tickets in 1946 but to go back to where
we are now what about the you know what
what governs the the right of a city you
know to of a mayor of a city council to
decay can declare emergency and then say
we're putting a curfew in place but
we're saying bars bars and restaurants
can't serve people in the premises
that's all legal that unfortunately
given American law the only way you can
challenge this would be under a sort of
delegation Home Rule doctrine
did the state when it gave cities powers
gives them the power to do this the
answer in most cases is yes and so what
happens is when I first wrote about this
on the Hoover site a week ago I
despaired of getting anything but this
was before the really heavy stuff came
now it seems to me that the only thing
that you could do is you could penalty
this looks to be crazy but you're doing
is you're assuming that everybody is it
equal stakes you're also assuming by the
way that there's gonna be no serious
collateral damage but here's just that
kind of a health risk you start being as
crazy about all this stuff as we become
and somebody gets very very sick are
they gonna find it as easy to get to the
hospital are they gonna have the right
care at home and people are prepared to
stay away but not to come in to assist
them what are we gonna do about the
major financial disruptions to me the
correct answer in all of these cases is
the first thing you do is you give
advisory advice and you look at these
numbers and you say anybody who's ill
you stay home it's not that you're going
to infect somebody else I mean that's
true but the thing you have to remember
is you're more vulnerable than anybody
else to any kind of random infection and
so there's a very low ambient background
quality of these viruses you're likely
to get hurt when somebody else is not
it's gonna be largely self enforcing and
if you certainly have newborns who don't
have full immunities you want to keep
them out of trouble and so forth but
generally speaking of you stolen to try
to look you can't see it so in New York
State they're about 10 best today my
guess is not
single one of these deaths came from
anybody who got a public exposure in a
bar or in a school and what happens is
we know in effect that that number of
people that we have in the state is
relatively low would say a thousand
people that exhausts the pool of people
who could of course this thing by
getting contracted two weeks or three
weeks ago so then you have to assume
that what's gonna happen next week my
guess is you'll see a kind of a modest
increase going on but the adaptive
responses will be so strong the thing
that is clear is most individuals when
you actually talk to them or more
cautious I think about this situation
then it warrants and indeed one of the
things that's kind of depressing about
all this is every private institution
that I'm aware of
has taken independent steps like the way
in the city so you know NYU just
announced it it's cleaning out its
dormitories of undergraduates all of
whom are age 20 and very healthy they
have to go home
we're not gonna have classes well I can
understand them saying okay professor
I've seen your 76 years old maybe you
ought not to be in school but suppose I
was 30 years younger I would certainly
want them to have the class going on so
I see what happens here is what you do
is you sum that everybody's in the
highest risk class then you overestimate
the damage to the highest risk these
institutions are going to suffer huge
amounts and my wife and I is we even
talk to people with when we do business
you know the exercise coach I have two
people start to cancel on that woman you
know how she's gonna be able to pay the
rent all sorts of things like you said
while you're paying you right now I mean
they're suspended classes and then or
you are you supposed to come up with
some kind of online or online
instruction um actually I will be doing
it back at the University of Chicago but
NYU is on full zoom mode professors by
the way I mean most of what I do is in
front of a typewriter or a telephone or
in front of a screen like this so
actually the kind of work that I do is
more isolated than most people when I do
missus companionship with my academic
friends and so forth because you can't
go to workshops and conferences what are
what are the better or smarter public
health measures that you think state
cities and and the federal government
should be taking what I mean they
shouldn't be
they shouldn't be bossing us around and
saying you can't go to the theater
anymore they you know they shouldn't be
shutting down things but but what they
shouldn't be taking over people's
businesses but what should they be doing
do you think that would have one the
first thing is they should publish
accurate information not hysterical
information and they really they seem to
out-compete one another and there is of
course a political science explanation
to this which I find it deeply
troublesome and I hope it's wrong which
is that if you're a progressive you
remember what Rahm Emmanuel said never
let a good crisis go to waste and if you
start looking at some of the proposals
they're putting they're having to do
with abortion funding and things like
this you realize that none of this is
related to any of the things that we
have so what you do is you always first
look for the low-hanging fruit and so
you restrict visiting how is it at
nursing facilities and old-age in
hospitals obviously you run much more
careful wipe-down
you develop a contagion Ward for people
who seem to be subject to the particular
situation and you give very special
protections and additional pay I daresay
to those people on the front lines
working with them in public spaces what
you tell people is you're gonna come
into this thing we're gonna basically
ask you to clean up that gym equipment
every time you use it then we're gonna
basically fumigate the place twice a day
in one form or another and then you can
see whether people will come back what
will happen is the younger people
knowing that the risk is lower and that
the conditions are safer we'll start
migrating in as they turn out to do a
little bit better than people had
thought others will start to follow and
slowly you'll get back to a much more
sensible type situation and so what
really takes place here is there is a
huge preference for all sorts of
institutional coercion by government and
then even by big private universities as
opposed to information spreading and if
you get the right information that's
gonna be spread then all of a sudden
people will start to differentiate
themselves because they will know
whether or not within any given age
culture and high risk a lot resized I
mean so like you know the operating the
the kind of ghost that this
banquet is really Typhoid Mary but what
you're saying is that this isn't typhoid
or is it that even typhoid should be
treated differently than it is in the
public imagination well it all this
stuff again depends upon the rapidity by
which things start to spread one way or
another and and there's no question that
early on when this thing is going you
may want at the beginning to sort of
slow down certain kinds of interactions
but generally speaking if you give
strong kinds of advices people will
respond to them and you'll start to see
a behavior what's so dangerous here is
that people are putting these things
into places if they're capital
investments that will stay in effect for
three to four months and this economy
cannot survive these kinds of shutdown
and you say okay what we'll do is we'll
just give subsidies to other people that
this is too massive to work you can
subsidize other industry from other
industries if only one is failing but if
everybody's undergoing the same kind of
convulsion you can't do it so
cross-subsidies around well you could
say well we'll just raise what taxes
well people are really gonna be thrilled
about paying higher taxes when they have
lower income but now we're we're talking
about cutting taxes right yeah and does
that work I mean you know half the
population faces very little by way of
taxes anyhow and rich people probably
they got a string of losses coming out
of this recent stock market debacle no I
don't think it works I don't think the
Fed changing the interest rates will
have to slide this thing to do with this
a quarter of a point one way or another
one for long term investing at the
margin but the other margins are so much
more important that nowhere lines gonna
start to say well now we'll resume well
fights because we could get gasoline for
fifteen cents cheaper a gallon than we
got it before so what is what if any
would you say and and again you know and
I want to be clear that you are
libertarian ish you're you know
absolutely but you're not you're
certainly not a hardcore you know
anarchists or anarcho-capitalists or
anything like that what do you think is
kind of philosophically what is the the
government's role in stabilizing or
keeping the economy afloat here and then
what can it actually do to affect that
of outcome because these and those are
two very different questions yeah I mean
the first thing is they have to rethink
some of the prohibitions that they put
into point on bars and restaurants for
example you know people will be aware of
them whether you keep these things or
not but what will happen is the
restaurants will start to try to
advertise our tables are further apart
than they used to be we're gonna give
you a reduction that is the firm's will
make intelligent responses and then
people could start to deal with it when
the government starts to take over it's
just everything is kaboom it's all or
it's nothing and now it's nothing and
there no kinds of intermediate adaptive
responses that can take plan so that God
the government's first job is not to
live not to put out these kinds of
studies which I think want only
overstate the particular risks good
question and well people gonna say but
these are professional epidemiologists
you know I don't care who's a
professional or not you don't win an
argument by showing you got a PhD you
win an argument by entering into a
public debate with people who disagree
with you and what's clearly happened and
this is there's no delay it's just
generally largely a monologue so I'm
sitting at home saying myself why is it
that I feel compelled to write about
this particular subject and it's because
I think either models won't be I've had
some familiarity with working with these
models going back 40 years to AIDS and
even before that on evolutionary theory
and that somebody just has to say look
they're two times to this particular
discussion and you know as you start to
see massive slowdowns in California and
understand that they're ten deaths in
the state from this stuff for which
happened three weeks ago you know six
people is not there you compare it to
the flu right the numbers are so
mind-boggling different and if this were
the propria thing and you'd have to shut
down the United States six months every
year this is the flu epidemic which
kills last year 50,000 people so
information is is the first step what
else should the government be doing to
kind of help the economy or maintain a
decent status quo during the corona
virus epidemic well but it ought to do
is not shut things down at the same
level that they've been doing it there's
no way that you can shut this down and
give subsidies there are only three ways
you can give subsidies you have to raise
taxes not gonna happen you have to
borrow money which is then what interest
already happening but it won't do any
good because the interest load is gonna
be there or you could print more money
at which point the money will be worth
less because the usual problems about
inflation and dilution of the currency
will start to take place so you can't do
this on the financial side the only sign
that works is to change the productive
side of the particular equation and
people have to start to think which of
the things that we are about to impose
can we do without and which of the
things can we get rid of and then what
you have to do is you have to unpack the
danger you shut down schools because
teachers are afraid to teach students
right because they think that everything
is going to start this bread well you
have to give them some probabilistic
stuff and then if the government had to
do something else this is what I would
do I would say okay we're gonna run in
this situation we want everybody to go
out there and what we will do is for
anybody who gets the virus as in the
course of their employment indeed anyway
but we will do is we will give you ten
thousand dollars towards your medical
care no questions asked and well all of
a sudden you know that's gonna because
you're a million bucks under the current
situation of five million dollars it's
not gonna cost you twenty trillion
dollars or whatever it is I mean I'm
friends of mine who suggested that the
GDP will go down by five percent that
strikes me as being very optimistic
given the massive dislocations that take
place and unlike the corona virus which
will get less serious as you go on in
time the financial disclosure financial
stresses the bankruptcies the reworks
will get worse as time goes on if you
look at the legal blogs as I have done
the single hottest topic now is vist my
or which is or force majeure depending
with you like French for you like land
it's big forces what it means and the
question is to what extent when you have
big forces do you excuse people from the
performance of their contractual
obligations and this is this is saying
that landlords can evict that
contractors don't necessarily have to
follow through etcetera I mean like this
is where you can default on you know we
don't know what it means it just means
whether the simplest case is that you
owe with
that the now this abyss my word you have
to pay or you're doing a construction
contract you have to continue well
suppose you don't have to continue you
still have to figure out you get paid
for the work that you've done to date
are you entitled to your profits can the
other guy throw you off the plant and
simply say that you're in breach when
you start to say that a contract is not
going to be enforceable it doesn't tell
you what is going to be done when that
non enforceability takes place there is
a kind of a standard rule about all
systems of law if it's just a question
of what's the right and wrong everybody
understands these rules you don't beat
somebody up you don't basically cheat on
a contract but it turns out if something
goes wrong and then something else goes
wrong you have to sequence the wrongs
and figure out the remedies that's when
90% of the action that lawyers do takes
place and all of these contracts are
underpowered with respect to this so to
give you but will isn't one illustration
you have the closed down of all these
sports arenas now the collective
bargaining agreement between the Union
and the league sort of has abyss mile
clause that the players themselves
probably don't get paid during this
right but if you called it correctly or
incorrectly maybe it changes but what
about all the people who work on
contracts in the stands the vendors and
so forth
are they on daily contracts so they
could be led off or the players gonna
try to put something together in order
to help these people
you just keep multiplying these sorts of
arrangements and so forth some contracts
a spot that is there for one shot only
some long term you will be very
preoccupied and what you will discover
is that the legal system when it deals
with messy remedies only surmise because
of the in frequencies of these cases
when you start piling on a hundred
thousand or a million of these things on
the same day each with its own variation
and you start looking at math such
principles is reasonably preventable and
reasonably foreseeable that's not gonna
give you the crystalline answer that you
want to solve these things on this final
final question how do you feel about the
next few months I mean not only is this
happening and it is a major major deal
going on right now but we've got an
election that is quite fraught coming up
in in a few months are you confident
that we'll have our [ __ ] together you
know say by the end of the summer
or will we be muddling through and kind
of doing worse than ever what what's
your sense of the next six months well
if I'm correct about that path of the
virus this means that you would expect
this thing to be a serious issue for
three weeks of for a month the way it
was in China the wait I think will turn
out to be in Italy the way it was in
Korea and so by May 1st or so you would
want to see things more or less return
to normal at which point you got six
months before the election but I gather
Ohio canceled its primary this very try
to yeah I mean it's a it's an
interesting illegal right I mean I think
in the end most people believe that this
will help Biden which I regard is a
terrible mistake the man is hapless as
far as I can see I don't think he's got
all his cognitive capabilities and when
he had him he wasn't very smart anyhow
Trump is obviously somebody who's
cautious instincts are slightly
libertarian but his public execution of
his duties slightly libertarian continue
down planting and more than the others
but you know he also believes that if
you could pull a political labrum with
transfer payments in one form or another
he's off work so my guess is you know
he's a C or c plus on this and buying as
a c- or a D plus on this you know I
count the differences but I don't look
forward to this with any deep optimism
and then when I'm of course afraid about
is that people are gonna treat this as
argument by saying AHA the progressives
were always right we have to redo things
so Bernie Sanders who knows nothing
about anything as far as I can tell
including health care now starts to say
the reason we have such trouble with the
virus is that we don't have a public
assistance program we actually look at
Italy the converse seems to be true on
all these public programs they have
insufficient funding for their
activities so what happens is they
rationed by queueing have insufficient
equipment they put people on long waits
and that may work sort of with elective
surgery it's not going to work with
these kinds of viruses so in fact the
socialist systems are much less able to
deal with this than the private ones
because I mean the American institutions
when it comes to you know the
operational aspects inside a hospital
and so forth these guys
very good at doing that kind of stuff
they may be doing the wrong thing struck
large socially but privately I'd much
rather have a hundred different
institutions figuring out adaptive
responses and cooperating then having
the CDC deal this I read a paper this
morning about the CDC and I think this
was a true yes you know this has become
a progressive institution under mr.
Obama so how do we care the ills of the
world well we start having affirmative
action programs of some kind or another
to root out racism and disease control I
took a position actually when I wrote
about this in about 2004 in the Brooklyn
Law Review the only thing you're caring
about with Public Health is epidemiology
and communicable diseases you're not
worried about obesity you're not worried
about lifestyles and so forth it's the
externalities that make it now at that
time I wasn't concerned about the abuse
of this public power which is here now
but it seems to me that once you focus
on what you should do you get a lot of
extraneous stuff off the table which is
good and then you have to think much
about Carter about what's on the table
and as far as I can tell this constant
repetition I'll just end on this note
that the exponential expansion the
geometrical progression will apply and
help the whole thing's clamps doesn't
fit with anything that I know about the
way in which these kinds of epidemics or
disease cycles happen to work well we're
gonna leave it there thank you Richard
Epstein of NYU Law School of University
of Chicago law as well as the Hoover
Institution this has been the reason
podcasts or the actually it's this is
the reason interview with Nicholas P
thanks for listening please subscribe to
us at Spotify at SoundCloud at stitcher
echo
Apple at reason.com / podcasts again
thanks for listening and be good thank
you
you
[Music]